but joining us right now here on the
Rich Eisen show is my colleague from the
NFL Media Group a future first-ballot
Pro Football Hall of Famer after 11
seasons with the Cleveland Browns and
now fresh off of an inspiring
performance on the Titan Games on NBC
hosted by Dwayne Johnson Mondays at 8:00
Eastern on NBC our buddy Joe Thomas how
are you Joseph I'm doing fantastic right
back at you Joe you know we were just
talking I was just reminiscing and I
actually dropped a rare s bomb for me on
this program it's kind of I guess the
mood I'm in this morning about all the
crazy stuff that happened in the first
quarter of that game in week 60 it feels
like 19 years ago based on everything
that's happened between then and now but
that Saturday game we call between the
the the Bucs and and the Texans and how
amazing it was that we were in that you
know pregame meeting Jameis had just
come off back-to-back what almost 500
yard games in a row right like 450 and
he was bouncing off the walls and
talking about how all of his receivers
were people that you didn't know anymore
he didn't know because both Evans and
and it in Godwin were hurt so and now
Winston is a saint man I mean it's
amazing how quickly things happen like
that right
yeah I mean it's almost a little bit of
a reflection on kind of where we are as
a country right now after you know four
months ago you never would have expected
to be where we are and kind of like in
that game now Tom Brady's at Tampa Bay
miss Winston it's gonna be and we just
kept looking at each other in the booth
going is this really happening it was
that pinch me moment and granted it was
my first time ever calling a game but I
kept thinking to myself you know all
these games go right like they're not
always dis insane they were insane like
that first quarter was insane and it's
crazy that that Winston's last pass as a
buck was a pick six that ended the game
if you remember against Atlanta that
overtime pick six that he threw and
Brady's last was a pick six in inning in
a playoff game and now they're kind of
swamped
it's so how do you think Brady and
everybody else is gonna do in Tampa
because it sure looks like this season's
gonna go Joe yeah III gotta think that
3d is gonna have a tremendous season I
mean that's where all signs are pointing
like we talked about they've got
tremendous weapons on offense something
that Brady probably hasn't had since
they had that great season where they
only had the one loss in the Superbowl
and he's reunited with Gronk and the
only thing that could hold back an
offense like that is if he had maybe
some question marks about the coaching
staff or the scheme but they don't have
that with Bruce Arians I mean you're
talking about one of the great coaches
in the NFL one of the great offensive
minds and a defense that's really
underrated when you look at their
defense
so really the thing that hurt them from
a statistical standpoint was their
scoring defense was because their
quarterback was turning the ball over at
a monumental pace and so I think we all
can expect Brady's not going to be
fumbling and throwing picks at the rate
that Jameis was and so that's just by
that nature going to help that that
defense and there's two just-so ranking
and they can get after the quarterback
they got a good defense so I think there
is nothing that's gonna be hold the
Buccaneers back a year it's interesting
to Joe and know we had Bruce Arians in
that pregame meeting as well the day
before and other than haven't you could
see he was he was a little bit chipper
to saying don't shake hands with Jameis
nobody shake hands with him because his
you know was throwing his throwing thumb
was was broken you know and and and he
was he was kind of having fun with it
but then we asked him as Jamis gonna
stick around here and he goes I think so
you know and he said we need to see how
these next two games go and we find out
subsequently then him and the rest of
the the Bucs were already looking over
the steering wheel and who might be free
and apparently they were already
thinking about Tom Brady at that very
time wouldn't you love to see that 34:30
right now and just see you know what was
going on with the back alley
communications and the wink nods and
kind of kicking the tires on stuff
because you have to think that they were
planning for potentially not resigning
Jameis obviously because they didn't
resign him
and you know it's just so many things
that I'm sure will come out 10-15 years
from now just as far as the the
speculation and the chatter and the the
conversations that the front office had
about who they think they can get and
realistically that first time I want to
love the benefi in the room in the first
time when they thought and they talked
openly about hey we really think we can
get Tom Brady to be a Tampa Bay
Buccaneer and the excitement the
enthusiasm that had to be just bouncing
off the wall in that meeting room when
they look at their roster they say this
is the one guy that we get and now we
are firmly a team that can win a Super
Bowl
right now Gronk's in the mix there with
OJ Howard you want to talk about a two
tight end said I mean that is
particularly dynamic and then you know
when they when they draft they did have
an opportunity to say you know to heck
with it let's go get another one of
these top-notch wide receivers stick him
out there with Godwin and with Evans and
with everybody else and let's roll but
instead they traded up one spot to get
Tristan wharfs and they're gonna kind of
move him around the line what do you
think of that and how you think he will
fit there Joe Thomas well I think that's
a really good move obviously they're
good at looking themselves in the mirror
and realizing yes Tom Brady is still a
great quarterback but Tom Brady is not
Lamar Jackson and we need to do what we
can to keep him upright I think they
they realize that the one weakness that
Brady is going to have right now
especially at this point in his career
is he's just not super mobile like some
of these guys in the iPhone so if they
want to make sure that they can be the
prolific offense that they know they can
be they got to protect them and Tristan
worse is tremendous town I got to watch
a lot of film with him and I got to see
him at the combine the guy could play I
mean he would have been the first tackle
off the board and nearly every other
draft it just so happened this was the
deepest tackle draft we've seen in a
long time and so picking a guy like that
especially when you have a position like
often to tackle that was a a position of
need for the Buccaneers we'll be honest
they struggled a little bit at offensive
tackle and so to be able to trade up one
spot and get their guy to be able to
protect their other guy Brady back there
I think that was the right move
what about the transition to move
positions Jill what do you make of that
you know I've talked a lot about it and
I'll use two guys is an example Mitchell
Schwartz Layne jobs and those are guys
that switch sides from college to the
pros and they have no problem I think
the transition gets a little bit
overhyped from college to the pros
because you just don't have a lot of
reps coming out of college I mean yeah
you practice yeah you play games but the
number of reps they're going to get when
they do start practice and they do start
playing games in the NFL is so
voluminous that they're going to be able
to easily override any coding that they
had in their brain that said I'm a left
tackle order right tackle where I get
nervous is when I look at like the
Giants and their potentially going to be
moving Nate's older over the right
tackle
I guess everyone I mean guys later on in
their career you know because you do
have a lot of muscle memory that gets
built up and that transition takes
longer to kind of change your mind and
change the way you kind of see your
muscle memory that that becomes more
difficult that's the transition that I
get more concerned with college the pros
to me that's no big deal a few months
and it's going to be like if he was
never on the other side I'll tell you
what solder was a I mean can you call
him a bust of a free agent Joe percent
or is it too strong well I I get nervous
calling my fellow former brethren animal
brothers bus because that is a very
strong label but when you are the
highest-paid offensive lineman in NFL
history at the time I think the Giants
and maybe hoped for some better
production let's let's put it yeah I
mean I mean you break the bank like that
right and then you have such a high
draft choice again and you take somebody
for his position essentially right since
you're I'm trying to match your
diplomacy yeah yes they're doing a great
job you pay a guy and now granted it's
somewhat a little different and free
agency because when you have a position
of need and there's a good player
available a lot of times you
have to reset the market in an
environment where the salary caps keeps
climbing and so that's part of the
reason he became the highest-paid player
in NFL history as an offensive lineman
not because the Giants thought he was
the greatest player in NFL history as an
offensive lineman however I do think
that they probably expected some better
production clearly or they wouldn't have
drafted a player of this position this
season Joe Thomas here in the Rich Eisen
show before return of the Titan games
let's talk about the team that's closest
to your professional home and Cleveland
where do you stand on the on the
maturation and the preparedness the
readiness to lead a team of Baker
Mayfield where do you stand on that
subject Joe there seems to be a lot of
conversation if he's ready or not the
new coach the old coach wasn't as good
for him after we hoped and you know
where do you stand on this subject so I
stand firmly in Madison Wisconsin
thinking about bigger Bayfield and I I'm
one of the people that was disappointed
and how he played last year probably
just like he was he played so well as a
rookie took that step back last year but
I have a lot of confidence and faith
that he's been saying and doing the
right things it's offseason I think he
really understands he looked himself in
the mirror after the season and was very
honest about his performance and why the
performance was that way and I think you
couple that honesty the self-awareness
with a guy like Kevin Stefanski who's a
new coach offensive coordinator who they
brought in there who's a very serious
very detailed offensive mind head coach
and and a lot of times as players you
tend to take on the personality of your
coach and I think Beggar's not going to
lose that gunslinger mentality because
that's what makes him great and you're
able to couple that and kind of harness
it a little but it reminds me a little
bit of Brett Favre with Mike Holmgren
era right you know Mike Holmgren
now he's different than Kevin Stefanski
but he brought that level of detail and
that commitment to the craft that
seriousness that Brent needed right it
was the yin and the yang and I see that
with Kevin Stefanski says Baker does
remind me
Brett Farve and his mentality about I
think I can make every throw but also I
think you need a coach that can help you
understand yes you can make every throw
but that doesn't mean you shouldn't have
proper technique or give yourself the
best chance of success on every throw
you shouldn't just be throwing off your
back foot in the triple coverage let's
take and make calculated risks so what
would what did go wrong there last year
chill what did happen well I think it's
like anything in the NFL you can't just
point to one thing and then that be the
problem but clearly the the coach player
relationship didn't work out because I
think you know Baker has that gunslinger
mentality that mentality that he can you
know get it done no matter what which is
great but I think you did need a coach
that's willing to harness you and it
didn't seem like he got that and it
didn't seem like the offense was putting
him and him the best chance for success
I think what Baker does really well is
he throws the ball on the move he's very
very good at scrambling and making plays
outside the pocket not in a unscripted
sense but running the bootlegs running
the play-action and that's just the type
of offense that they're bringing in
there right now is Kevin Stefanski
they're running the white zone to build
the Shanahan scheme where you're gonna
be running wide zone they've got two
great running backs they're gonna be
very good at running the football but
then that's where the play-action pass
the bootlegs are so dangerous because
you get those huge wide-open holes in
the secondary because defenses have to
sell out to stop the run game and Baker
makes plays as well as anybody outside
the pocket throwing the football and I
just think it's it's a really good fit
and he seems really motivated dedicated
and I think he understands that look you
have one good year and then one bad year
your third year is really important in
the NFL when you're on a rookie contract
and this you know maybe saying a
make-or-break season is too hard but I
think that's the way that the team is
looking at they're like hey this is the
year that's going to really solidify our
opinion of Baker and if we want him to
be the guy that is the face of the
franchise for 15 years or if we need to
start thinking about maybe he's not the
locker manager Joe Thomas here on the
Rich Eisen show
so are you tight with the rock now you
in the rocker or BFF he's in my circle
five right then I get free texting
nights and weekends list now you could
say that we're not owned by AT&T anymore
so you can do that that's not a problem
since so you I mean look at you on the
set of the Titan games man look it's
here right there Jeff fun it was really
what's cool I mean for me I love being
retired and spending time at home and
being able to you know rub elbows with
great guys like Rich Eisen yeah on the
sidelines of games and you know in the
booth but getting back out there I
didn't realize how much I missed that
competitive environment and just going
out there and kind of pushing yourself
to the limit and it might not be that
fun to work so hard that you get blurry
vision and you feel like you're gonna
pass out
but I tell you the feeling when it's
over it's pretty good and I definitely
missed that adrenaline rush and then I'm
talking about all just being able to
meet the rock and spend some time with
him and talk with him and the other
competitors so that was really special
you know my my life's pretty simple
these days and so having big moments
like that was was really cool and I
finally we watched the show with my kids
yeah and it was really cool because of
the first time I've ever seen them get
excited about something I did oh that's
great ran my football career I had a
helmet on and and there were a little
bit younger and there were some concept
of hey that's daddy on the field or
that's daddy and it's cool that he plays
football but all of a sudden I'm hanging
with Maui from Moana your welcome is
what he said he would say you're welcome
that is great so your kids have never
said Wow dad I'm so glad you were able
to keep spurge and win upright so you
never had the Titans game provided you
with that did you talk to Dwayne Johnson
about his football prowess because we've
had Warren Sapp talking about
this show talked a little bit and he's
very self-deprecating about his football
career I wasn't old enough to play with
him or supply but he did not make it in
the NFL and I think he was a lot better
yes from what I heard it has all worked
out for Dwayne there's there's no doubt
about it and then you know we were
seeing your your I guess this is a the
head shot if you will the promotional
photograph of you for the Titans games
how long did it take for you to get this
look down what were you going for here
was this a blue steel situation or what
are you going for right here with this
this look your arms are crossed you know
obviously you got those biceps and then
and everything's working out right there
look you know Ed Hochuli would be
jealous of this right here what's the
look you're going for right here you
know I'm working on a second career as a
male model clearly and so I was trying
to put that out there my portfolio there
you know potentially for the future so
if you wouldn't mind you know just keep
sharing that with know your remodeling
business me my pleasure cuz you're
definitely like you know staring at the
camera I'm a little bit frightened but I
do know you personally so I'm able to go
on with my day how much weight have you
lost from your playing days oh I'm down
about 50 pounds from my last season and
about 70 from my heaviest my heaviest I
played it about 2/3 302 315 and then
sort of the middle of my career I when I
was still feeling pretty good the knees
were too banged up I played all the way
up to almost 320 and I felt pretty good
but as my career aged a little bit I
just couldn't carry as much weight
because it just hurt my joints and my
back so much and so it was better for me
to be a little bit lighter but yeah I'm
I'm down like 50 pounds I feel a lot
better
what do you seriously think of when you
see an old picture yourself you see my
wife and I we always laugh like it was
it was the fat Joe era but you must
think about you know just to all the
days I guess it took to to keep that
weight on I imagine right oh yeah
I mean I think about it sometimes when I
sit down at the table and I eat like a
salad and I'm like man this is the time
where I wish I was still fat Joe and I
was getting paid we'd be fat and I could
eat ice cream and cookies and lasagna
and every me alone yeah I felt like I
was doing something good you did a good
job to work you're doing it for work you
can actually eat ice cream in lasagna
and say I'm doing this for work you know
yeah yeah I wish I had the perspective
at that time to appreciate it maybe I
you know go back to those days would be
nice no no you look great man last one
last one for you I know when you were
drafted and you know we identify will
not work on our draft show when we're
alive on the air we kind of there was no
zoom I mean we kind of I guess Skyped
with you or something you were fishing
you're fishing with your dad right is
that what you were doing on your wall
okay so I know you're a fisherman I
don't know if it's the same type of
fishing but what'd you think of the 440
two-pound Marlin that Michael Jordan
reeled in did you hear about this uh-huh
I did not but I'm definitely gonna check
that out I I've always had this dream
since I was a kid I got a book when I
was like 10 about black marlin and
Australia and like grandeurs you know
one one thousand dollar Marlins and I
was had that dream of going out there
and catching one so for Michael Jordan
to catch a foreigner powder that'd be
awesome I gotta check that out I am
apparently talking it down it's was 440
2.3 pounds I don't want to forget the
0.3 butt hole he was on the boat but he
was part of it but where everybody's
giving him credit he wasn't he wasn't
the angler nor the captain it's his boat
it's his boat it was catch 23 and
where's catch 72 docked right now I'm
good but maybe Michael send me an invite
someday because there's like a lot of
fun yeah the bay the big rock blue
marlin tournament you know in North
Carolina is where that took place the
rumor is that Marlin talked tons of
trash
you just he was not he was gonna take it
personally but Mike took a person the
old-school man in the sea right Joe
thanks very much appreciate it brother
you take care of yourself and and I'm
glad you had fun on the Titan games and
that firefighter and shoot from Chicago
was quite something
we've Matt channel you took on in that
regional finals that was that was a
close competition right there man yeah
everybody in my family was sad when I
lost the other night except for my son
who has become a huge match and so I
think I might be giving him a match and
fat head or maybe good guy second I
can't feel sad about Joe I'm so psyched
that you had such a good time with your
family over something like that to watch
dad do do something that's cool dude you
take care of yourself we'll chat soon
okay Jake appreciate a man that's Joe
Thomas at Joe Thomas 73 hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here